armelle cherrih quelles mesures peuvent
être prises pour sanctuariser les
centrales nucléaires alors déjà c'est
compliqué parce que des centrales
nucléaires elles sont dans la zone
civile donc du coup assez pour ça vous
voyez que vous avez pas mal de l'apd
personnes qui se sont mobilisées pour
essayer d'être autour et qu on est en
plus en ukraine dans un pays qui a connu
de tchernobyl donc il ya déjà eu un
nuage radioactif qui est passé et qui
est extrêmement sensibilisé à cette
question donc le président céline ce qui
quand il prend la parole il sait que
tout de suite tout le monde va l'écouter
et puis dans le monde partir du moment
donné où vous parlez de centrales
nucléaires il ya le risque évidemment
d'un bombardement et donc d'avoir des
radioactivité derrière donc tout le
monde est en éveil à côté de ça les
regarde et ce qu'ont fait les russes ils
sont très stratégique les russes dans
leur conquête territoriale aujourd'hui
ils ont besoin de prendre cet axe là
parce que c'est logique c'est sur leur
remontée en fait fait ravir kiev ils ont
réussi à gagner en fait tous les
territoires du côté de l'est et aux
autour de la mer d'azov alors et encore
des lieux de batailles mais donc ils
sont sur leur remontée et cette centrale
nucléaire elle existe à ce niveau là
cette centrale nucléaire elle les
intéresse d'abord parce que ça faut ni
d'électricité ça leur fournit de la
richesse ensuite quand ils ont ciblé
d'après ce que l'on sait ils ont ciblé
un laboratoire et ils ont ciblé un
document à un endroit administratif pas
les réacteurs ils n'ont pas intérêt à
frapper en fait sur les réacteurs parce
que à côté d'une part cette centrale
elle est sûre le lièvre donc ça veut
dire que vous contaminer riez tout le
demi après et les cours d'eau 2 au 12
qui descendent vers l'acquis de remake
justement qu'ils ont pris et ensuite
vous contaminer riez toutes les plaines
fertiles qui font des céréales à côté et
qui sont la richesse de l'ukraine
potentiellement demain la richesse de la
russie si la russie met la main dessus
donc en quelque sorte les centrales
elles se sont tus risque comme ça on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un fou on n'a
pas d'assurance très précise que tout ce
que je vous dis soit exactement comme
cela mais en tout cas avec du recul
quand les russes ou dix on a pris cet
endroit là on comprend qu effectivement
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait pour que des
pourparlers soient réellement un prélude
à une négociation éventuelle il faut à
un cessez le feu pour l'instant on n'a
que l'accord sur les corridors
humanitaires pour évacuer les civils on
a que l'accord sur les connu madore
humanitaire mais compte tenu de la
situation c'est déjà pas mal j'avais à
dire je dise alors pour l'instant sais
pas où est ce qu'ils vont avoir lieu on
sait pas comment est-ce que cela va se
passer
mais on est dans une situation de force
ou vladimir poutine et entra à la
manoeuvre militaire d'avancé donc il n'a
pas scellé un cessez le feu et à
vladimir poutine en règle générale n'a
pas non plus intérêt à laisser fuir trop
de civils parce que les civils dans la
logique russe ce sont des gens qui
peuvent être des combattants de demain
peuvent prendre des armes et puis
peuvent revenir simplement la réalité
c'est que l'ukraine ses 40 millions
d'habitants qu'on va pas tuer 40
millions d'habitants que derrière on
peut pas cru si des femmes et enfants il
a bien dit qu'il voulait faire attention
à la population civile donc il faut
laisser ces corridors et surtout quand
il y aura les villes assiégées c'est à
dire que s'il se passe quelque chose à
kiev qui va à un moment donné être
complètement dans un goulot il faut bien
laisser les familles s'en aller c'est ce
qu'on a pu en syrie sur certaines zones
marioupol par exemple est totalement
encerclé aujourd'hui on sait pas du tout
si on peut parler de ça mais c'est dans
ce cadre contexte là qu'il y aura la
possibilité d'avoir des corridors
humanitaires pour un moment donné dire
aux civils partez merci beaucoup armelle
charrier pour votre analyse merci à vous
déjà après la ville de